the US Supreme Court stopped an
execution in Arkansas overnight just
minutes before the inmates death warrant
was set to expire Arkansas asked the
justices to remove illegal stay imposed
by a lower court on the execution of Don
Davis but the Supreme Court denied the
appeal in a one-sentence order Arkansas
had wanted to execute as many as seven
inmates by the end of this month
Omar Villafranca is outside the state
capital in Little Rock with now Arkansas
is now trying to resume capital
punishment for the first time in more
than a decade
Omar good morning good morning Don Davis
is on death row for the 1990 murder of
Jane Daniel when the Arkansas Supreme
Court stopped his execution the state
appealed to the US Supreme Court late
last night with minutes before his death
warrant expired the Supreme Court
weighed in about 15 minutes to midnight
the Supreme Court weighed in denying
Arkansas's appealed to let the execution
of convicted murderer Don Davis go
through we were told that he was in a
waiting cell late Monday night the state
was still preparing for Davis's
scheduled execution Bobby
Amazon with Arkansas public media was
picked to be in the room we were told
that the prison was fully staffed to
perform an execution at any moment Davis
was one of a group of seven men on death
row whose executions have been scheduled
over two weeks governor ASA Hutchinson
wants to carry them out before the
state's supply of midazolam one of the
controversial drugs used in the
execution process expires at the end of
the month the drug has been associated
with botched executions in four states
we are committed and working every
single minute to ensure again that
justice is carried out Arkansas Attorney
General Leslie Rutledge has made
numerous legal appeals there's a wrong
thing to do and there's a right thing to
do last week actor Johnny Depp joined
activists at a rally against the death
penalty these are people that I lived
with for almost 20 years Damien Echols
was freed from Arkansas's death row in
2011 and has become an advocate against
the death penalty Echols says he
personally knew many
the men more sentence to die I can't
make them do anything all I can do is
say please reconsider ask look what
almost happened to me the state isn't
slowing down the execution schedule two
inmates are scheduled to be executed
this Thursday governor Hutchinson says
he plans to fight all appeals for the
victims families
all right Omar thank you